près de quarante ans après l'éradication
de la variole et scientifiques de
l'université de l'alberta ont recréé un
virus très semblable en achetant des
produits sur internet l'expérience donne
froid dans le dos fait craindre
éventuelle guerre biologique tu l as
fait trembler l'humanité entière et tué
des centaines de millions de personnes
la marianne est une maladie redoutable
est extrêmement contagieuse
au début la maladie présente des
symptômes semblables à ceux de la grippe
puis des éruptions cutanées apparaissent
sur le visage le cou et le reste du
corps environ le tiers des patients
succombant la maladie en 1796 le médecin
anglais edward jenner test pour la
première fois un vaccin contre la
variole
c'est un succès il faudra toutefois près
de deux siècles avant que la maladie ne
disparaisse
c'est à la fin des années 1960 que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé oms
met en branle une campagne de
vaccination massive
le 8 mai 1980 l'om est ce déclarent que
la variole a été éradiquée de la surface
de la terre
le virus est conservé dans seulement
deux laboratoires ultra sécurisé
l'un aux états unis et l'autre en russie
depuis des années des membres de
l'assemblée mondiale de la santé oms
plaide pour que ces dernières soient
détruites pour des raisons de sécurité
d'autres croient qu'il vaut mieux les
garder pour continuer à étudier le virus
est mieux se préparer au cas où la
maladie réapparaîtrait
les chercheurs de l'université de
l'alberta en couper court à ce débat en
synthétisant le virus de toutes pièces
dans leur laboratoire pour éliminer les
risques de contamination le professeur
dvd venus et son assistant de recherche
ryan white ont synthétisé le virus de la
variole équine
la souche qui affecte les chevaux
sa structure est très semblable à celle
de la variole humaine mais elle est
inoffensive pour l'homme
les deux virus celui de la variole
équine et celui de la barrière du maine
sont composés d'une membrane à
l'intérieur de laquelle on trouve une
longue chaîne d'un dé m l'adn rappelons
le est une succession de nucléotides qui
s'assemblent comme des blocs lego
il existe quatre types de nucléotides ou
quatre types de blocs lego représenté
par les lettres à tcc et g l'adn du
virus de la variole deakin par exemple
est une chaîne de 212 mille nucléotides
assemblée dans un ordre précis
l'équipe 2 des veuves et veufs et ryan
white a reconstitué cette lan chaîne à
partir de petits morceaux d'année à
l'artificiel acheté sur internet
en effet il existe des compagnes et qui
synthétise et vend des courtes chef de
nucléotides les chercheurs de
l'université de l'alberta ont rassemblé
les courts segments dans leur
laboratoire pour reproduire à
l'identique la séquence du virus de la
variole équine
ils ont ensuite transféré in vitro cet
adn dans des cellules de mammifères
le virus de la mare hier liqin aussi
virulent que le virus d'origine a
commencé à s'y multiplier pour fabriquer
le virus de la variole humaine
il suffirait de changer quelques lettres
dans la longue chaîne d'art des aides
officiellement l'équipe de l'alberta à
réaliser cette expérience pour soutenir
la recherche de vaccins au cas où une
nouvelle épidémie de variole
surviendrait mais dans les faits elle a
surtout prouvé au monde entier que la
synthèse du dangereux virus était à
portée de main des bioterroristes
c'est un scénario cauchemar une arme
biologique lancé sur une ville où placer
dans une station de métro à l'heure de
pointe des premières personnes touchées
affecterait les autres en quelques jours
selon des voeux d'avèze des groupes
terroristes pourraient vraisemblablement
synthétiser le virus de la variole
humaine les techniques qu'il a utilisés
sont facilement accessibles aux
scientifiques qui maîtrise la biologie
moléculaire
son équipe n'a mis que quelques mois et
investit 100 mille dollars pour arriver
à ses fins
en principe les sociétés qui vendent des
segments de l'adn doit faire des
vérifications et s'assurer qu'un même
client n'achète pas des séquences qui
pourrait mener à la création d'un virus
dangereux mais les criminels peuvent
déjouer ses contrôles en achetant des
segments auprès de différents fabricants
les pays développés ont des plans
d'intervention en cas d' attaque
biologique
on dispose de vaccins et d'antiviraux
pour contenir des épidémies mais ils ne
sont pas à toute épreuve
et aujourd'hui on vaccine plus contre la
variole l'accomplissement des chercheurs
canadiens oblige à réfléchir les
activités de biologie synthétique exige
une meilleure surveillance
[Musique]